Now let's see how to implement
an interstitial ad in Android Studio.
And for this I'll be using
the Amazon Mobile Ads API,
which I've downloaded from
their developer site.
If you still need to download that API,
please refer back to our reading
node for instructions, otherwise,
follow along with my code and
we'll test our end result together.
So I've opened Android Studio and titled
a new project named My Interstitial Ad.
You can name yours whatever you want,
but
keep in mind that it's always good to
have a clear and descriptive name.
Then let's create a new
blank activity and
I'll name it Interstitial Ad Activity.
Okay, great, and we can see we have
a few bare bones things in here already.
We have our xml layout file here,
and our interstitial ad activity.
The most important method to us here
is going to be our on create method,
which sets our view up so
that we can display our interstitial ad.
So I've copied this Java file,
and pasted it into our project,
in the Java lives folder.
Then we need to click it and
say add as library.
Now, we should be able to open it,
and we can see all the classes and
interfaces that we have access to,
like add layout and listener, and also,
interstitial ad.
We also need to add a couple lines of
code to our android manifest XML file.
So let's take a look at that.
Inside our applications tag,
I've added lines that reference
Amazon's ad activity package.
And outside of the application tag,
you can see that I've also declared
the permissions we need to use, which
let us use the Internet to retrieve ads.
I've also added these extra runs that
allow us to get the user's locational
data, these can be useful if you want
to target ads to specific location.
So make sure you've changed your android
manifest and included your library.
And now, let's dive into our Java
code to make an interstitial ad.